and I think we have some great things to
talk about I'll start by discussing the
Federal Reserve as you know it just
happened two minutes ago but to me it
makes me very happy and I want to
congratulate the Federal Reserve for
starters they've lowered the Fed rate
from what it was which was one to one
point two five and it's been lowered
down to zero to 0.25 or 0.25 so it's
zero to 0.25 that's a big difference
it's a it's a quite a bit about a point
and in addition very importantly the
Federal Reserve is the going to be
purchasing 500 billion dollars of
Treasuries and 200 billion dollars of
mortgage-backed securities and that
number can increase but they can start
with that and that's really good news
it's really great for our country it's
something that we're very happy I have
to say this up very happy and they did
it in one step that didn't do it in four
steps over a long period of time they
did it on one step and I think that
people in the market should be very
thrilled and that brings us with the
strongest country in the world by far
financially in every other way and that
brings us in line with what other
countries are there actually they
actually have negative rates but look we
got it down to potentially zero so
that's a big step and I'm very happy
they did it and you will not hear
anything bad about me unless it's about
a month or two from now
you